so I'm making bagels from scratch I've
only made 200 so far hi guys I met a
tasty producer and today I want to find
out if it's worth making your own bagels
at home or if you should just buy them
from the store so I'm gonna prep my
ingredients and get started I buy most
of my bagels from the grocery store so
for this first comparison I've decided
to use the brand that I usually get it's
pre sliced and consistently good which
is really all you can ask for from a
prepackaged bagel my second comparison
bagel comes from a well rated bakery
here in Los Angeles and yeah I know New
York has some of the best bagels in the
world luckily most the reviews said that
these were the closest thing they'd had
to new york-style bagel outside of New
York and honestly I kind of agree with
them they were made fresh the day I
bought them and they looked and tasted
amazing this homemade recipe was
developed by her food coordinator Alexis
and was tested many many times by both
of us and I mean so many times you have
no idea how many bagels I made bagels
are deceptively simple-looking sure they
don't require that many ingredients but
there are tons of ways for things to go
wrong and I know because I messed up so
many times
speaking of mistakes you cannot
substitute for bread flour you need that
nice gluten development to get the right
consistency and texture because of that
do not consider kneading the dough by
hand the quickest way is with a food
processor if you try to knead it with
your hands it'll take close to a half
hour to reach the right consistency
you're not making bread so the dough
should not be moist and gooey it should
be a bit firm and very very stretchy
like a rubber band but don't over need
or you'll end up with maybe dense rings
oiling is how bagels get their shine and
chewy texture now I use barley malt
syrup for color and flavor
the water tray is optional but I found
that whenever I used it my bagels cook
more evenly and didn't burn as badly
[Music]
what you do is ready feel free to divide
it into six or eight pieces keeping them
as uniform as possible you can use a
scale if you really want to be specific
about the sizes of them now this is not
the official bagel forming technique
that professionals use so this method is
what worked best for me given the
constraints that I had you're basically
working the dough so that the surface
stretch is tight and the seam on the
bottom gets as small as possible poke a
little hole through it and gently
stretch the ring out rotating as you go
make sure to take your time if you go
too quickly you'll tear the dough and
it'll burst open in the oven
and I'm gonna be real this step is
exhausting it's a real arm workout but
persevere it's totally worth it in the
end
[Music]
now I boil my bagels for about 30
seconds aside however if you want
chewier bagels you can let them go for
up to a minute
just don't let them go for too long or
they'll overcook an egg wash is optional
but it guarantees the bagels will be
shiny and golden brown on the outside
plus it's how you get the topping to
this day and you can use whatever
toppings you want feel free to
experiment add a little bit of fun
sesame and poppy seeds are good enough
for me though and that's it you've made
bagels their best if you eat them right
away
within a day they'll get pretty stale
it's a lot of work but if everything
goes right I promise you'll be proud of
the bagels you've made so how did the
bagel stack up the store-bought bagels
are the cheapest but barely beat out the
bakery ones the homemade ones are the
most expensive which makes sense given
the cost the serum used on all the
ingredients the store button Baker style
bagels are also the most time-efficient
taking a matter of minutes to prepare
while the homemade ones take hours
store-bought and bakery are also the
least challenging all you have to do is
toast and top it took 16 practice
batches for me to feel confident making
bagels from scratch the store-bought and
bakery bagels are much easier to clean
up after as well
homemade bagels require the mountains of
equipment and cookware that need
cleaning but ultimately it all comes
down to taste in a blind taste test my
co-workers favorite the bakery and
homemade bagels for their balance of
flavor and texture so should you make
your own bagels at home no absolutely
not if you like a challenge by all means
go for it I'm proud of myself for
tackling this but they take way too much
time and effort to justify making on a
regular basis store-bought is great it's
convenient and consistently good but
nothing beats a bagel from a bakery
they're fresh and chewy and delicious
and by buying them you're helping
support a local business and I think
that's the best way to go
eeny meeny miny moe that one
[Music]
you